cette usine traite 40 mille tonnes de
bouteilles en plastique chaque année
dont une grande partie au final recyclé
pour le contact alimentaire un site
implanté dans la zone portuaire de lyme
est prise en exemple par le gouvernement
la secrétaire d'état la transition
écologique et solidaire brune poirson et
son homologue à l'économie et aux
finances
agnès pannier rue nash et se sont rendus
sur place elles ont signé vendredi 18
janvier le contrat stratégique de la
filière transformation et valorisation
des déchets c'est très difficile de
recycler et de fabriquer des guides de
faire du plastique qui est compatible
avec un usage et avec un contact
alimentaire est ça la france c'est faire
une usine comme celle ci le prouve ici
le déchet est une ressource et qu'en
fait à terme l'objectif c'est que on ne
parle plus de déchet mais bien de
ressources
donc il ya un enjeu qui à la fois très
industrielle un enjeu qui est très
écologique
il ya un enjeu qui est très sociale en
termes d'emploi pour développer cette
filière de la transformation et de la
valorisation des déchets le contrat fixe
six projets structurants notamment
l'accompagnement des acteurs du secteur
et du potentiel de recyclage accélérer
la robotisation des centres de tri ou
encore développer l'offre de formation
et de certification
la problématique c'est de se dire
comment mettons nous en place des
filières industrielles rentable puisque
on a mis en place la technologie après
faut mettre en place le reste et en même
temps de mettre en place tout
l'écosystème qui a été décrit par les
deux ministres à savoir
l'éco construction la capacité d'avoir
des produits qu'ils soient recyclables
etc etc etc
toute une série de choses qu'il faut
mettre en place si on veut véritablement
que ces filières démarre en 2015 en
france 3 124,5 millions de tonnes de
déchets ont été produits 75% de détritus
ménagers ont été valorisés